meine Damen und Herren wir können sagen
die SPD hat die
Sondierungsrunden die wir uns
vorgenommen haben abgeschlossen wir
haben jeweils dreimal mit der CDU und
dreimal mit Grünen und Linken gesprochen
wir konnten heute die noch offenen
Themen alle abarbeiten und werden jetzt
in der
sondierungskommission so wie Sie hier
sehen uns beraten werden noch mal alle
Gespräche auswerten werden auch darüber
sprechen wie
einerseits das Wahlergebnis zu bewerten
ist noch mal in der Rückschau wie wir
inhaltliche Schnittmengen auswerten
miteinander und wie wir auch die SPD
zukunftsfähig aufstellen und über all
diese Fragen werden wir jetzt im Detail
sprechen und werden dann ähm auch eine
Empfehlung erarbeiten die wir dem
Landesvorstand dann vorstellen werden
wir haben heute verständigt dass in
Respekt auch der noch offenen
Sondierungsgespräche zwischen GRÜNEN und
CDU
morgigen Tag noch keine
Landesvorstandssitzung dazu stattfinden
soll sondern dass wir das aller
Voraussicht nach am Mittwoch machen
werden so dass jetzt die Kommission sich
zurückzieht alle Ergebnisse auswertet
und dann eine Empfehlung ein Votum auch
entsprechend formulieren wird und im
Landesvorstand dann das vorschlagen wird
das war ja unser Auftrag ich erinnere
noch mal daran der Landesvorstand hat
uns beauftragt in beide Richtungen zu
sondieren Aufgabe der
sondierungskommission ist es jetzt eine
entsprechende Empfehlung auszusprechen
und die werden wir auch entsprechend
jetzt erarbeiten damit ist die
sondierungsphase ja kann man sagen
beendet und wir werden so ist unsere
Planung in dieser Woche also wissen in
welche Richtung dann auch
Koalitionsverhandlungen gehen werden wir
haben ein
Weg gefunden der ermöglicht der
Zielsetzung des Volkes entscheidet zu
entsprechen aber eben auch ganz klar
verabredet wie eine eine ein
Lösungsansatz aussehen kann und das ist
etwas was natürlich auch mit der
cdu-thema war denn wir haben ja alle
miteinander die Aufgabe dem
Volksentscheid gerecht zu werden und die
Expertenkommission wird eine Empfehlung
aussprechen deshalb muss jede Partei
jede Regierung sich damit
auseinandersetzen wie mit dem
Volksentscheid umzugehen ist dafür
Lösungen aufzeigen und das haben wir
entsprechend auch verabredet wie ein Weg
sein kann wir hatten
einen sehr intensiven Arbeitstag
zusammen sind durch die großen wichtigen
Themenblöcke und Themen auch für die
Stadt durchgegangen wir haben über die
funktionierende Stadt gesprochen über
Wohnungspolitik über Klimaschutz und
mobilitätspolitik über Bildungspolitik
über eine saubere sichere Stadt und
attraktive öffentliche Räume und über
die Stadt der Vielfalt
so und sie sehen insofern wir haben ein
dickes Arbeitspaket hinter uns ich würde
sagen wir haben in all diesen
Themenfeldern
offene Fragen geklärt und auch gute
Lösungen gefunden für die Stadt